[MUSIC PLAYING]
We live in an
increasingly cynical age
where romantic love
has been distilled
into algorithms of data.
Where love is reduced to nothing
more than the neurotransmitter,
dopamine.
Biochemically, no different
than an addiction to cocaine.
Imagine that, right?
The romantic passion of the
lover, reduced to a coke head
on a coke binge.
There's something kind of
cynical about this resignation,
about letting go of
that ecstasy of love
that inspired the
Romeo and Juliet story.
The archetype of finding
"The One", that is as God.
These encounters with
these divine beings.
To put the lover on a
pedestal and lose oneself
in an ecstatic sexual worship.
A stage-managed
resurrection, an apotheosis.
I mean, that's the kind of
love that I still crave.
That's why we still
go to the movies,
and we're moved to
tears by moments
of tenderness and beauty.
Those in-between times.
You know, those
moments of pillow talk.
An inter-subjectivity.
Those moments of the happy/sad,
where your lover looks at you,
and you look at
them, and you see
yourself being seen by them.
These moments, these
exchanges, these intimacies,
these moments of
consummation, I think
they still live in the back
of our psyches, hinting,
hinting at greater,
greater intimacies.
And greater exchanges, and
deeper, higher fidelities
of nuance and intimacy
with the other.
And that promise, I
think, keeps us searching,
and keeps us chronically
dissatisfied.
We will not settle.
We will not let go of
that romantic dream,
of that moment, those
goosebumps, that tenderness.
Hey guys be sure to check out
"The Dictionary of Obscure
Sorrows", which is literally a
compendium of words we've never
heard before, used to describe
elusive feelings that we
can barely ever articulate,
but we will surely recognize.
Check it out.